une seule question ce soir comment
comment tout cela at il pu ce passé
qu'elle a été l'enchaînement des faits
qui a abouti au drame dans toute
catastrophe il y a une part de hasard et
une part de responsabilité explications
patrick esther hier soir vers 18h55 sur
la voie numéro deux de la gare
souterraine de paris lyon le train pour
villeneuve saint georges est à quai un
autre train parti de melun se dirige au
même instant vers paris lorsque cette
trame de banlieue arrive à proximité de
vert de maisons
un passager va tirer le signal d'alarmé
ce qui entraîne l'arrêt automatique de
la ram acte de malveillance probable
dire à la direction de la sncf
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à cet instant là
les freins fonctionne parfaitement pour
réenclencher le système le conducteur
doit descendre de la motrice c'est
peut-être à ce moment là que le circuit
d'air comprimé des freins est tombé en
panne après un bar et de 26 minutes
lemelin paris repart il est à 8 km du
terminus son trajet est suivi par le
poste de régulation de paris sud est
le conducteur aperçoit un premier signal
jaune mais la vitesse est réduite
il sait qu'il peut facilement arrêter le
train si le feu suivant est au rouge
et effectivement le feu suivant est au
rouge
le conducteur déclenché les freins ceci
ne répondent pas il ne reste plus que
six cents mètres avant l'entrée en gare
il prévient par radio le poste de
régulation
il sait déjà que dans trente secondes
son train va percuter quelque part le
conducteur essayent alors d'actionner le
frein de secours en vain
la ram ralentit à peine devant lui il
reste beaucoup d'aiguillage pour dévier
le train fou mais les aiguilleurs donc
que quelques secondes pour choisir un
nouvel itinéraire
ils doivent éviter de faire se percuter
deux convois en marche
des convois nombreux à cette heure
d'affluence ils doivent aussi éviter
d'envoyer le convoi vers la gare
aérienne le train en défonçant les
butoir pourrait tuer des centaines de
personnes dans le hall le sort est joué
lemelin paris se dirige vers la voie
numéro deux de la gare souterraine où le
pari villeneuve saint georges en retard
sur l'horaire est encore à quai
à 60 kilomètres/heure la motrice va
percuter la ramie mobile en montant sur
la première voiture elle va emprisonner
les voyageurs entre les deux planchers
est ce qu'avant hier soir vous imaginiez
pouvoir vous retrouver sans frein du
tout je dois dire que non jamais à aucun
moment quand on monte dans un train on
se dit qu'on peut avoir ce type de
d'ennui aucun conducteur ne peut
imaginer que qui va avoir une rupture de
freinage
c'est à conserver auparavant dans
l'esprit des conducteurs comme dans
celui des techniciens tout problème de
freinage ne pouvait qu'entraîner l'arrêt
du train
[Musique]